all right so we've had our crazy Kitty
version of Snow White now have the
really dark adult version of Snow White
or at least adult ish any case I was
looking forward to this movie so let's
review it Snow White and the Huntsman
alright so Snow White and the Huntsman
is the story of Snow White the second
one this year and it's a very different
tone than Mirror Mirror this is the snow
white movie that someone like me can
really sink my teeth and do you know I
mean from the trailer you can tell
you're like that almost looks like Snow
White meets Pan's Labyrinth and in some
parts of the movie you're like this is
snow white meets Pan's Labyrinth there's
some scenes where she lay everything
spores hid her face he's tripping balls
there's trolls and trees that are coming
alive shits trying to kill her I was
like I played this in Diablo 3 just
today this happened I feel your snow
wise like you're on hardcore mode don't
die don't die or so by now we know the
basic story of Snow White you know you
got the Evil Queen and then Snow White
and Snow White's locked in a tower than
Snow White escapes and the Evil Queen
just causes death and decay throughout
the kingdom and Snow White needs to feed
her for the sake of puppies and
Christmas and everything good ooh gotta
be Pete can I say Christmas any more is
it holidays now Christmas whatever and
as someone who's looking forward to this
movie I can say I actually dug this
movie the Evil Queen is evil and there's
murder and really gross dark spells like
some spells she cast you know she's like
crawling out of tarush blood you're like
that's a bad spell that's not a spell I
want to be a part of first of all let's
talk about Charlize Theron as the Evil
Queen she was hot as hell and evil as
hell she is really bad in this movie
that's one thing you gather you're like
that is one evil woman and I like the
relevance that the Queen actually had
you know usually in movies like this
it's like a big evil person they're
doing evil things because they're evil
but there are a couple parts where
you're like you were a person at one
time and it wasn't one of those forced
moments Villa ah here we're gonna give
humanity of the villain half that's
officially what they do when they throw
force things in movies hey yeah there
were a couple moments where you were
like you were a human being now you're
just so bad sometimes she kind of annoys
you in the sense that she seems like
just some chick with a grudge like a
grudge against dudes you know she's like
if I were young you'd break my heart
you're like uh let me guess someone
broke your heart is that why you're
killing everything in the world are you
like the she Anakin but looking past
that she does a really good job but just
showing that she
is evil incarnate she's like Satan let a
chick congratulations to my
ex-girlfriends for being a character in
a movie but if there's one thing that
does a really good job at kettering a
movie it's a good feeling she did a good
job as a really good evil villain next
we got Kristen Stewart as Snow White
alright you know me and Kristen Stewart
I can't stand her I don't know why it's
just that same performance she gives it
everything you know she's always like I
talk like this like I'm really damaged
and I barely even move my lips when I do
it however I felt it worked in this
movie because she would have a lot of
damage in her she's seen her father dies
she's been locked in a tower dungeon all
her life yeah I'd probably be a little
damaged too I'm not saying the woman has
range I'm saying that her typecast
worked for this movie you really felt
like Snow White and the Evil Queen we're
opposites they were polar opposites of
each other that Batman Joker feeling you
know like the two are connected and they
just they have to fight its fate then we
have Chris Hemsworth as the Huntsman I
liked him as the Huntsman of course you
knew from the trailer you knew from the
moment you found out Chris Hemsworth was
the Huntsman you were like that's
perfect you had no gripes about it any
gripes you might have had about this
movie had nothing to do with Chris
Hemsworth and of course he was good as
the Huntsman my only gripe is that he
didn't steal the show I liked him in
characters like this you know the
brigand the Han Solo in medieval times
steal the show in the end he wasn't the
one who stole the show I felt it was
Charlize hotness is the Evil Queen
hotness who gets older throughout the
movie it's really cool though she gets
older throughout the movie because she's
decaying I'll say this in the end of the
movie and I almost want to say spoiler
alert but I don't think it's a spoiler
because you know that Snow White's gonna
have to face the Evil Queen at the end
but when she does it was almost like
dude this is Castlevania it's like this
Chi Castlevania really I felt like
Kristen Stewart was the she Belmont
going up against the evil hawk Queen
who's like she Dracula Kristen Stewart
should be glad that she didn't have to
go up against death because he's always
the biggest dick Boston every
Castlevania game he's always the hardest
Haiti another thing I like is that Snow
White is like the she Messiah you always
got that in all the snow white tails
always like oh she's the fairest of them
all she's gonna bring peace to the land
but he never really got that she's the
one she's neo
she's like the neo of the snow white
world and I really like that this movie
Illustrated that my grapes are fee but
they are in it one of them is that
Kristen Stewart gets attached to these
characters throughout the movie and of
course the bad guys are on their trail
then this town gets burned down -
supposed to be this big tragic thing but
you're like well
is tragic for her but you weren't with
these characters long enough to really
care I feel like you were supposed to be
but you just weren't in the end Snow
White and the Huntsman is a really cool
movie a cool take on Snow White I like
the characters even Christian Stewart's
really stoic overly damaged persona
worked for this movie I will say I would
buy this movie on blu-ray if you're
overly hyped for this movie which a lot
of people are you might be like oh this
movie was totally over hype doesn't mean
the movies bad it's just that you piped
yourself up a little too much but a good
movie I'd recommend it to people alright
so what's your favorite dark fairy tale
you know a lot of fairy tales out there
but what's the one where you're like
yeah that's just not the kids shouldn't
hear that movie's fable fantasy whatever
doesn't matter I don't care comment
below let me know long as it's near and
dear to your heart as a fairy tale it's
all good to me man and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more